[Musik]
das war ja klar
im jahr 2009 10 ist das essen grün und
sieht irgendwie synthetisch aus science
fiction filme hatten uns gewarnt
[Musik]
zum glück ist auch das angesagt eine
saftige poulardenbrust mit einer
kräftigen dicken und weinhaltigen soße
einmal im jahr berichtet die
österreichische
ernährungswissenschaftlerin hanni
rützler in ihrem food report über
aktuelle trends 2009 10 kommt die
französische küche zurück allerdings ein
wenig anders hier gesellen sich zum
kopfball
falafel und couscous statt wie üblich
alles mögliche aus kartoffeln bewegen
liebevoll neu bisschen leichter bisschen
frischer macht aber auch neue anschlüsse
reinlässt hanni rützler ist unterwegs zu
helga einem wiener startup helga das
steht für health lg also gesunde da ist
es nur ein grünzeug in reinkultur
austria samen haar für mich und
getrockneter chlorella alge entsteht ein
pudding
[Musik]
schöne kombination zarte alge eröffnete
clip ist eine antrags fällt als die
getrocknete die man vom asiaten kennt
gut könnte mir gut vorstellen
der nächste snack ist bekannter algen
cracker und als tipp ein eigenes gogreen
so das motto einer bewegung die auf vier
chlorophyll in der nahrung setzt weil
der grüne farbstoff vitalisiert wie auch
in dieser limonade über 50% der alge es
ist eine mikroalge ganz klein aber die
hälfte davon besteht aus problem und das
ist ganz besonders spannend wenn wir uns
überlegen wie kann man acht oder zehn
milliarden menschen auch in zukunft mit
protein versorgen
hier im deutschen bundesland sachsen
anhalt werden die trendy süßwasser ein
gezüchtet in einem mit wasser gefüllten
glas röhrensystem insgesamt 500
kilometer lang
diese systeme lassen sich dort bauen wo
normale land wirtschaftlich möglich ist
also auch hier können wir unabhängig von
fruchtbaren böden landwirtschaft
betreiben
kombiniert mit diesem rasanten wachstum
der algen ist das ein riesiges potenzial
zumal die algen auch alle nährstoffe
enthalten die wir von lebensmitteln eine
rösler besucht die testerei einen wiener
laden mit einem bislang einmaligen
konzept der besucher kann hier
innovative produkte von meist kleineren
firmen vor dem einkauf probieren
die testerin verkostung slokar
immer noch angesagt der langzeittrend
insekten hier als studentenfutter mit
grillen und würmern
finde ich ganz wunderbare mischung wie
diesem zeugen von den bären und dass die
nüsse unterstreichen nochmal dieses
nussigen aroma von de-mail firmen also
schöner leichter snack und mit der
wunderbaren portion und schließlich der
letzte trend hält eine gesunde
genusssucht klingt wie ein widerspruch
in sich aber wenn es richtig gut und
gesund ist darf auch geschlemmt werden
gesundheit in unserem kulturraum hat
sehr früh geheißen zu gut ist muss es
ungesund sein und in frankreich war es
genau das gegenteil der fall wenn es
nicht schmeckt ist es nicht gesund punkt
und so hält mal wieder französisches
savoir vivre einzug in das s und
lebensgefühl verzicht war gestern der
tag an dem es nur noch einen gibt der
kommt schon früh genug
[Musik]